hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be looking at the budapest game but
we're starts out with pawn to d4 Knight
f6 pawn c4 then black is going to play
pawn to e5 giving up material in the
second move and after pawn e5 black is
going to play Knight to g4 attacking
this e5 pawn a lot of times you'll see
players move their Knight to e4 trying
to get rapid development with their
minor pieces I really don't recommend
this instead I highly recommend moving
Knight to g4 which is the common move
attacking the pawn on e5 and putting a
lot of pressure on that Square and from
here we're going to take a look at the
three main lines that you'll see white
play and the first one is Bishop to f4
typical development move for white at
the same time he is putting central
control with his bishop at the same time
he's defending this pawn on e5 Black's
going to continue his development with
Knight to c6 and at the same time while
he controls the center he's going to
attack the pawn on e5 again White's
going to do the same with Knight to f3
developing his knight and defending this
pawn on e5 now black would like to bring
his Queen to e7 and put more pressure on
this pawn but he doesn't want to block
in his Bishop so instead he's going to
bring his Bishop to b4 first check and
now that his bishops out then he can
bring his Queen to e7 putting more
pressure on this pawn on e5 now White
has two options here the first one is
for him to bring his his Knight to c3 if
he does this white in the end is going
to be up and material he's going to
continue to be up that pawn of material
but he's going to have doubled pawns
here after Bishop takes on c3 and white
recaptures with pawn takes on c3 why
it's going to contain this material
advantage but it does have double pawns
on this C file and it's going to be
tough for him later on in the endgame to
hold on to this advantage
if he does instead move his knight to d2
as you'll see black and equalising
material but why it's going to have a
double bishop pair and he's going to
have a little better development of his
pieces so we're going to take a look at
the continuation of the mainline and now
black is going to bring his Queen to e7
attacking this efj I've pawned a little
bit more there's nothing white can do to
hold on to this pawn from here White's
going to play pawn to a3 attacking his
bishop trying to get it get it out of
the way it's pinning down the whites
Knight to the King and at the same time
it's just troublesome for whites who
have to development his pieces when his
King is pinned down by this bishop so
after a three blacks going to play
Knight to e5 black has more attackers on
the e5 pawn so he's going to go ahead
and start to capture from here white has
two options as first is a huge mistake
if you've seen the video on the condom
to trap its pawn takes on b4 you won't
see this very often but if someone does
fall for this trap then you can play
Knight to d3 checkmate so you can see
the King can't move and this pawn cannot
take our knight on d3 because our queen
is here on e7
hopefully you do see that but more than
likely you won't see that instead you'll
see night takes on e5 and from here
we're going to take again with our
knight and like before he cannot take
our bishop here because we can come to
e-excuse me d3 again it's going to be
checking it instead you're going to see
pawn to e3 this opens up for his light
squared bishop to get into the action
defending this pawn on c4 and at the
same time giving his King a little room
to breathe if he wants to next move he
can capture our Bishop on b4 now would
not be wise for what White's going after
to take on e5 if someone does do this
that's completely fine but the reason
why it's giving up the exchange that he
is to equalize the material and giving
up that pawn is he wants to have the
bishop pair from here he's going to lose
his Bishop pair if he takes on e5 but I
can play D 2 and after white captures
black and recapture and black was
equalized in material and development
and this is really not that good for
white and so a lot of times you won't
see black take with their bishop on e5
instead you're going to see pawn to e3
like I said before and then from here
black is now going to move his Bishop
just take on d2 and blacks going to
recapture with his queen on d2 and as
you can see here why it has the double
pair of bishop he has decent development
Black has equalized in material which is
exactly what we are going for he has a
knight inhibition this is completely
fine game for both sides White's up a
little bit the blacks not too far behind
and with a nice little in-game blacks
going to have a completely fine game in
a situation we're good so we'll go ahead
and take a look at the other two main
lines that you may see in the budapest
gambit and again starts out pawn d4 and
after Knight f6 on c4
and capture and we play Knight to g4
another movie Macy is pawn to e4 a lot
of players if they're not too familiar
with a gambit as soon as they take the
gambit pawn on e5 they're going to give
it right back to you and they'll do this
after we recapture on e5 they're kin
they're going to continue to push up
with their pawns putting a lot of
pressure on the center and trying to
gain a spatial advantage on black
what black really needs to do now is
maneuver his minor pieces so that he can
undermine the central control the pawns
later in the game so that's really the
struggle that that it comes up both
sides are equal and material advantage
life is going to try to overextend why
it's development of his pawns further
down the board he's going to try to
undermine them with his minor pieces
later on in the game in the last line
you may see in the budapest gambit after
Knight to g4 you may see Knight to f3
again simple development with his Knight
f3 attacking defending this pawn on e5
but you can see there's a little bit
difference in the move order from before
when the bishop came to f4 first and
from here blacks going to again
put a little different move order
himself he's going to bring his Bishop
to c5 he's not going to bring his Bishop
to b4 and he's going to bring it to c5
and he's putting pressure on this f2
pawn as you can tell we have our knight
on g4 and so white has to figure out a
way to do to block this so from here
going to see pawn to e3 and already you
can see how things have changed before
blacks excuse me white now has his dark
squared Bishop blocked in so he can't
bring his knight
excuse me his Bishop to f4 to hold on to
this pawn on e5 so from here things are
a little bit different now black can
bring his knight to c6 now he has two
attackers on this pawn on e5 and white
can no longer bring his bishop to this
f4 square but you'd really like to be on
to hold on to this c5 pawn white is
going to have to give up this ephod pawn
earlier than he would like to where he
would if he brought his Bishop to f4
first you can see how different it is if
the knight comes to f3 first before the
bishop to f4 and now we also have our
Bishop on c5 instead of b4 which is a
lot different as you'll see later on
from here you'll see the bishop come to
e2 for white and blacks going to take on
e5 equalizing material and from here
black white will capture and black will
recapture and from here White's going to
play a3 these are just the main lines
and blacks gonna play a5 getting ready
for a nice little maneuver after white
castles and black castles White's going
to develop his Knight to c3 and bless
going to get ready for rook lifts and if
you're not too familiar what a rook lift
is basically it's bringing your pawn to
a5 and then playing rook to a6 getting
ready to swing your rook over to the
h-file
getting ready for a huge attack on the
kingside of white the black queen can
come to h4 and he can do this because
the knight on f3 for white is no longer
there this would not be possible if the
knight for white was on f3 because he
could just kick out the Queen on h4 at
the same time black and bring his Knight
to g4 put a lot of pressure on this h2
square
if white ever plays a move h3 like has
the option of developing his
LightSquared Bishop after he moves his D
pawn and sacrificing his Bishop on h3
putting a lot of pressure on White's
King and he can get a lot of his pieces
attacking the White King fairly easy the
only downside of a rook lift is we don't
develop our LightSquared Bishop early on
as you can see our LightSquared Bishop
is pinned in right now and if white pays
attention to this he can really focus in
on this weakness this is huge weakness
for black now black can position his
pieces nicely against the king side the
black is going to have a really really
good attack against white so these are
the three main lines that you'll see in
the budapest gambit hope you guys
enjoyed the videos if you haven't
already please subscribe and I'll see
you guys next video thanks for watching
our body